that's sweetheart oh you're a sweetheart
like you all right this is all right
sweetheart okay i like you already i
don't like this
i don't like this
my name is kings i am 22. i'm on here
today to find my love
i'm here to find the girl of my dreams
do you think it's possible to form a
romantic connection only through a chat
room
if i don't get to see you i don't
necessarily you know get to judge you
and i guess i could overlook certain
things
so being able to see like your actual
the depth through the conversations you
know
make like a greater connection could be
better in the long run looking for my
wife so
um you know that would be sad if i
missed the one if i just missed the one
because
uh because of you know maybe some
message or something so
if i end up uh eliminating someone and i
look around and she turns around that's
like rihanna or something i don't know
we'll see
we'll see i'm not a total pushover but
if you look like rihanna you know i
don't know so things might be
they gonna be different so we'll see
we'll see
wow they're going pretty quick hello
how's everyone i got to test the waters
i can't be too crazy
i'm just trying to stay sane during this
quarantine time
highly favored okay bill nye fan account
very calm
very confident how are you
kings wow okay taylor thank you for
asking me direct question
you're a sweetheart oh you're a
sweetheart like you all right
i don't like this okay we're making a
first good impression
he already said my name ibs queen is
so boring i hate that his name is king
because like i have to call him king
villain
for king sleep oh okay there we go
kingsley
i really love that name that's a cute
one uh let me see what other questions
do i have
where are you all from
i can do distance you know i'll drive
for 30 hours for you for our love i will
drop 30 hours from
san diego socal canada and i got to do
some passport things for that you know
we figure it out
i'm the only canadian here what about
you
i feel like you have to be reciprocated
when i try to
ask about him too
my family's from boston i'm gonna ask
you have a boston accent that's the
first thing that pops into my mind
i cannot have a blossom accent
we're going back to life this works out
maybe we'll move back to l.a feel like
i'm more interested in getting to know
the girls right now
what is their favorite things
to do during the
quarantine hopefully none of these these
answers are boring if you're boring i
just can't i can't rock with you i can't
buy with you i'm gonna say watch avatar
on netflix i feel like a lot of people
are watching avatar
watching avatar on netflix interesting
last airbender
i mean okay i watched it when i was when
i was kind of a child
i'm thinking of like random hobbies like
via tiktok
very educational actually i've been
songwriting a lot and i just released an
album on spotify overachiever much
of course everyone gives deep answers
when i'm just like oh avatar
you know i've been songwriting
she's got some flavor to it that's gotta
be an la short it has
okay so i'm seeing a lot of netflix i
get it it's quarantined but she's just
kind of lazy there's a lot to do what's
your what's your sign oh
no your sign
let's get to the nitty gritty i'm a
gemini people don't really like gemini
you know i'm a capricorn but like i
don't believe in them honestly gemini
yikes he said gemini yikes
let me change your back oh geminis are
crazy
oh my gosh i hope that that's not like a
a turning point
gemini stole 500 from me i'm still salty
bill nye is really bringing me down i
don't know what a gemini is i don't know
i don't know any signs i'm trying to
scare them you know i know people are
into this i'm not crazy about it you
know
oh she said let me change your mind
confidence
sagittarius he's a
is sagittarius that's a great sign oh
here's a question i actually care about
hold on
how tall are you i'm five five
i hope that's not too tall i'm five six
on a good day you know they're good
the mood okay everyone's a pretty tall
queen i feel like sometimes when guys
find out that you're tall really they're
like no
man
one of them said i'm 5 11 lol i don't
know
we'll see the tallest person here i'm
going i'm leaving
i'm leaving i just know it's going to
happen oh god kingsley how far are you
five five eight
kingsley's five eight he's five eight
i could be his mother that's okay you
know what that's okay just play it uh
just playing just like just playing
where's my bible there is a god i almost
kicked myself out the chat
that experience was pretty interesting
interesting interesting interesting
first round everyone seems to be you
know very happy with each
other and like you know i love that
environment no i hope i don't get
eliminated it's anybody's game it's
anybody's king
it's anybody's king why am i like almost
sweating
my stomach is dropping suspense
i don't wanna see
[Music]
i'm sorry artsy muffin and i'm also not
a big fan of muffins too so it didn't
really hit with me
at all yeah but i'm excited to go along
with the other girls let's see it let's
do it baby let's run it up looking for
my wife
[Applause]
[Music]
oh god here we go i'm just going to go
in with a high just give me a
high real quick list three things that
you love about yourself you know how
confident
and comfortable are you with yourself
how much do you love yourself my
listening skills my passion for singing
and my love to connect compassion
family and sense of humor my
humor enthusiasm and my ability to
connect i'm not gonna lie man she might
i think she hit it all my answers were
perfect
that's a great answer thank you kings
what are you obsessed with these days
honestly tick-tock
once we meet i can show you
it must mean i can show you is that too
bold i've never
i flirted i'm like i guess maybe a
physical touch and quality time type of
person
that's the surface these are good
questions i really love the name
kingsley like that name is so perfect
my mommy named me you said my mommy
that's why my um like favorite name is
uh for the longest time what
my mom used to work at a bank too oh his
mom used to work at a bank too
oh my god match made in heaven huh
can you send a picture oh
you're yourself it's sending oh my gosh
i'm freaking out that's funny
he called me beautiful oh he's a little
suave oh
that's a cute as well i'm about to be
like where are you from again where are
you from
again um and i'm going to send her a
picture
he's handsome oh my gosh he's so
cute i'm very handsome thank you
the scary thing is is that i'm setting
these pictures but i had
no idea what he is saying and thinking
so that's
kind of uncomfortable oh she's had a
couple
oh now i gotta send two of course he he
gotta send
he got us in a shirtless one i mean it's
not a picture unless it's shirtless
right
i wish we could talk more
i'm gonna throw it hard anyways i'm
gonna flirt i'm a flirt oh he sent me a
heart
heart at the same time oh you feel my
energy like what's up
overall i think that went pretty well i
think it went well
that went by really fast we had a lot to
talk about i like that we didn't send
pictures right away
so that we form that emotional
connection first it's giving bachelor
it's getting bachelor
two people who i gotta eliminate oh i'm
not gonna lie
oh no oh my god i'm kind of
i'm looking through the conversations
right now and everything's just tough
he's typing again i don't know ah
i just can't not really not to tell
girls like 5 11 is just really tall
beautiful and all i just cannot
yeah this is so evil this is the most um
i'm sorry damn well i mean i thought our
competition was going well but
apparently not i don't know it could
have been
my picture maybe it wasn't serious
enough so maybe that was like
too goofy maybe he just thought like i
wasn't serious enough
[Music]
hey so this is what my voice sounds like
just to make sure
um i was wondering if you know the
reference of my username
i'm done why do they sound so creepy
your voice sounds lovely i do not know
the reference
of where that um of where i could have
done my croissant is i don't know maybe
that's the l on me i'm sorry
are you the singer are you one of the
people who said they can sing if you can
sing
show me something come on it's a chance
i am not the one that said i can sing
okay the username is from an
iconic vine that i'm so sorry that you
missed out on
stop i could have dropped my croissant
but no i did not say i can sing i'm the
dancer i'm the person i can dance
oh wait how are your tic-tock skills did
i ask you that um i'm not really into
tick-tock dancing
dances i've never done one so no
tick-tock dances
not even a little like i'm scared
hi kingsley i just want to know how you
would describe your best friend
also hi nice to meet you through voice
memo
now this is the most nerve-wracking
round i think something about not being
able to actually see them and them just
hearing your voice
hello hello what's up take take you know
i just i it's got nothing for you super
quick um
describe my best friend but i can say
all them are goofy as hell super goofy
and um
super loyal i guess my best friends are
the people who've really been there like
for like 10 plus years of my life i like
that
he has a nice voice he sounded nice i
feel like you can tell when
like how a person is by the way they
talk kind of
i feel you kingsley well i know we
didn't get to really talk
all that much but i think you're really
handsome and you're really nice and i
love that you're able to
talk about things that aren't so surface
level so
if this doesn't work out i hope that we
can still be friends and i wish you all
the love and all
the best bye taylor sounds a super
super thoughtful message
me and you i could have dropped my
croissant is he typing i wish you the
best i love this type thing
this is very suspenseful nervous that's
what it feels like to be on the bachelor
i do not like it
[Music]
i couldn't draw my cursor i made it oh
my gosh oh it's funny
i'm sorry we just didn't click on the um
on the uh the name
i feel like i'm on a netflix dating show
where we get to run to each other but
it's on zoom oh my gosh i'm so nervous
i'm just really hoping to see that if
it's you know love at first sight you
know i'm hoping to get that
aha moment i mean i already know what
she kind of looks like hopefully she's
not catfished
[Music]
hi how are you i'm good how are you
good i'm good congrats thank you i i
can't believe i got picked but i felt
like we were really connecting from the
start
and when you called me tate and the
voice memos i remember from the
beginning
you're the first person to come ask me a
question in the um you know that was
super thoughtful i think that
i literally it did leave a mark on me
you just met but you know um you know if
you are my future girlfriend or even my
future wife because i did say hey
i'm on here to find a wife that's just
the reality you know if it doesn't work
out it doesn't work out it's fine
but um you know i like that if you're
not looking for you know
to actually be with someone or date
someone you're just kind of looking for
someone to talk to
absolutely you know especially
especially with this quarantine thing
you know i'm saying i need a quarantine
bag and i love your background too you
know maybe it's a uh
forecasting for oh i don't know you know
we'll see hold on let me
show you what i got in my background
he's like a baby cheetah he's so cute
his name is royalty royalty royalty and
kings
kings and i are still talking we're just
getting to know each other despite the
distance we're still staying connected
and i feel really really lucky that
jubilee allowed me to
virtually meet someone as cool as kings
and i think it's going well but me and
taylor are chatting here and there you
know
my whole goal from the show you guys
know my goal i want to get i want to get
married i want to find me a wife whether
it be taylor hopefully it is so um
you know i want to be able to come back
on here two three four five years from
now and be like
yo shout out to versus shout out to
jubilee hey i got my wife from here that
would be beautiful taylor if you're
watching like
let's see how it goes you know